some say it is the price of the pandemic
a cdc reports a 48 percent increase over
the past year of emergency room visits
for teens who've attempted suicide and
unfortunately some do sadly die by
suicide sally jeremiah live outside of
centennial hills high school with more
on the passing of one of their students
sally
brian very sad news the principal of
centennial high school sent a letter
home to parents yesterday indicating
that a 16 year old student had died at
the school
tonight students and health had died
excuse me tonight students and health
experts say mental health is a serious
crisis in our schools
lisa durett is a child and adolescent
psychiatrist and assistant professor for
the kirkur korean school of medicine at
unlv she says in their practice they've
seen a rise in children that are in
crisis jarrett adds emergency rooms for
suicide attempts and boys only rose 3.7
percent and jumped 51 percent for girls
we just have to be really alert and
aware right now that our kids have been
struggling for a couple of years duret
recommends parents have open
conversations and do what they can to
support their children at home also
check in on social media accounts for
clues into your child's mental
well-being
back out live if your child needs
support we have posted some information
on our website a number they can
privately call or even text
live local now